one of the central principles of my life
is that no one knows enough to be a
pessimist about anything take what it is
that you would really like to attract
into your life whatever it is and want
it more for somebody else than you want
it for yourself when you have an image
that you can succeed excel at something
you will start acting on the image that
you have what a soar get a mentor what's
up leaf nation it's heaven I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
today let's learn from one of the best
way Dyer and his five key principles for
living a fulfilled life mentor me Wayne
also if you wanna know Wayne Dyer other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day to the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
have a mind that is open to everything
and attached to nothing
[Music]
okay let's take it off with principle
number one be open-minded have a mind
that is open to everything and attached
to nothing one of the central principles
of my life is that no one knows enough
to be a pessimist about anything and
that each and every one of us when we
close our mind to what is possible for
us or what is possible for Humanity
closes off the genius that resides and
lives in each and every one of us having
an open mind doesn't necessarily mean
finding fault with all of the things
that you've been taught by others it
means opening yourself up to the
potentiality and the possibility that
anything and everything is possible so
having a mind that is open to everything
and attached to nothing really means
finding within ourselves the ability to
get rid of a trait that I find so common
in contemporary in the contemporary
world do you know that most people that
I meet spend their lives looking for
occasions to be offended they actually
are out there hoping that they can find
some reason to be offended and there's
no shortage of reasons they're out there
everywhere the way this person dressed
what the worst person said they turn on
their TV they hear the news they're
offended by this
someone didn't someone use language that
they didn't like someone doesn't share
the same customs that you and people
have all day long in fact if you keep
track tomorrow you will find probably a
hundred reasons that you can go around
being offended but a mind that is open
to everything and attached to nothing is
a mind that says I'm never looking for
anything to be offended by
and that whatever anybody else out there
has to say my response to that is that's
an interesting point of view I've never
considered that before principle number
two shift ambition to meaning my friend
Byron Katie says that who believe that
you need what you don't have is the
definition of insanity to believe that
you need what you don't have because
you're already here so you've already
proven that you don't need it so the
goal around believing that I can't be
happy fulfilled you know whatever it is
unless I get this stuff that I don't
already have it's a complete and total
illusion it's a it's a thought that
isn't even true this there's no truth to
it whatsoever you don't need anything
and when you get that the irony is
you're no longer you're no longer
attached you're your total life is about
it's just about living those virtues how
can I serve how can I be sincere how can
I be gentle how can I be supportive and
thinking like that and that's how I
think now and because of that I'm I'm in
meaning and being in meaning the times
that I was in ambition you know is is
delivering more and more and more and
more of what I wanted so much then and
now that I'm not attached to it it's
like I can just be like the I can be
like the cat you know I can just go
about my business and just let it follow
after me wherever I go so what I say to
people who really want to access the
that the transition from you know from
ambition to meaning if they really want
to access it is to get your thoughts off
of yourself I do it on the radio every
every Monday and it's like all all my
questions you know all the questions are
about why can't I manifest this why
can't I have that this isn't working and
so on and my response back to them all
the time over and over again is take
what it is that you would really like to
attract into your life whatever it is
whether it's wealth a job you know money
a nice watch a new car whatever it is
and want it more for somebody else than
you want it for yourself just just want
it more just think about that and and
think
about how much joy it would give you to
be able to put your attention on that
and just keep your thoughts on that you
know take your thoughts off of yourself
and start living the four virtues start
being sincere sup start being supportive
you know start having this reverence
reverence for it for their life and so
and just shift off of what's in it for
me you know and and how much am I gonna
get and why isn't it here fast enough
and how much else and why is there
shinier than mine you know and so on off
of that and and begin to project that
and do that I don't feel whether you're
a school teacher it does I don't care if
you're a dental hygienist or if you're a
carpenter or you know whatever it is out
there that you are doing if you can take
your attention here if you want the door
to open if you want the door to open to
meaning then the only way that door is
gonna open is if you understand that you
have to leave your attachment to this
grossly world of the material things and
what's in it for me and how much am I
getting and shift your energy your
thoughts onto how may I offer how may i
sir principle number three visualize the
image that you have of anything in your
life is really like mental behavior it's
like going on in practicing if you go
out and practice with a basketball
shooting free throws over and over again
that's physical practice imagery is
mental practice it's mental behavior
when you have an image that you can
succeed except at something when you
have an image that you can do it rather
than that you can't do it when you get
into your car and you have an image that
you're going to find a parking place
rather than that there'll be no place to
park so you're not looking for no place
to park you will start acting on the
image that you have very much like you
will start acting on the practice that
you have when you're shooting baskets or
when you're hitting a forehand or or
working on your soup or anything else
that you're doing principle number four
don't die with your music still in you
the next principle I call don't die with
your music still in you and who better
to quote than Thoreau right here in
Concord when he talked about some of us
hear a different drummer and we must
march to the music that we hear but all
of you everybody watching everybody here
in this
beautiful perish all of you have some
music playing and all of you have a
heroic mission there's no accidents in
this universe we all show up here with a
purpose there's an intelligence that is
a part of everything and everyone and
all of us are connected to it and too
many of us are afraid to listen to that
music
and March to it you out there I know you
have a book you want it to ride I know
there's a composition you wanted to
compose I know there's a song you want
to sing someplace maybe you want to
raise horses out in Montana or maybe you
want to open up an ice-cream shop on
Cape Cod who knows what it may be maybe
you just want to travel and see the
world maybe you want to go into a
relationship with someone but you've
been afraid to but your heart says it's
the right thing to do all of us feel
something and in Leo Tolstoy his famous
novel the death of Ivan Illich he asked
this question that would be terrifying
to me he says as he has this accountant
from Moscow lying on his deathbed
contemplating the horror of this
question what if my whole life has been
wrong I've known what my music is it's
playing right now as I stand here in
front of you with these cameras and in
this place
and as I sit down and write my books and
tell the world what I know are my truths
I feel always completely on purpose and
fulfilled and no time will I ever come
to the end of my life and say what if my
whole life has been wrong whoever you
are whatever that music is however
distant it may sound however strange
however weird others may interpret it to
be don't get to the end of your life and
know that you're going to leave and not
have it played yet
don't die with your music still in you
in principle number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
think small and achieve great things
thinking small is what gets great things
done verse 63 achieve greatness in
little things take on difficulties while
they are still easy do great things
while they are still small the sage the
sage one of my daughter's names the sage
does not attempt anything very big and
thus achieves greatness greatness comes
from being in the moment here present in
the now the sage confronts difficulties
but never experiences them this is the
idea of thinking small and finally I'd
like to see you change from this thought
change from seeing yourself as separate
to seeing yourself as connected to
everyone and everything in the universe
I've got a really special bonus cup from
Wayne Dyer on how to walk down another
street that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing question it's time
to move from just watching another video
to take an action in your life for
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what's
the music inside you that you need to
get out before you die question number
two how can you shift ambition to
meaning and question number three where
do you need to be more open-minded so
this was something that Portia Nelson
who I knew who passed away a few years
back 10 years back now she lived up in
Seattle and she had she was at a seminar
and they were asked to write the
autobiography of their life in five five
versus five chapters so and they gave
them only like cards this size actually
they were smaller than this they were
three by five cards so right out
chapter 1 of your life and just go to
where you are today and I remember doing
this very same thing but what she wrote
was so brilliant that I asked her
daughter if we could put it on public
television which I did on the most
recent show and we made a contribution
to Porsha's work so this is what she
wrote down in the chapter fives of her
life chapter one she said I walk down
the street there's a deep hole in the
sidewalk I fall in I'm lost I'm helpless
it isn't my fault and it takes forever
to find a way out chapter two of my life
I walk down the same street there's a
deep hole in the sidewalk I pretend I
don't see it I fall in again I can't
believe I'm in the same place it isn't
my fault it still takes a long time for
me to get out chapter three of my life
I walk down the same street there's a
deep hole in the sidewalk I see it there
I still fall in it's a habit but my eyes
are open I know where I am and it is my
own fault and I get out immediately
chapter four of my life I walk down the
same street there's a deep hole in the
sidewalk I walk around it chapter five
of my life finally I walk down another
Street now grade
[Music]
if you want more Wayne Dyer motivation
check out the four hour long video we
made on him you will love it the link is
right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there
ten principles that I have put together
here for this program you might want to
jot down you might want to go into your